Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history we continue with our world cup marathon and today we are in the far east we are in south korea the land of k-pop and the squid game uh but also dominic um yes tom well i'm leaving it hanging because I was hoping that you'd come in because your choice of theme today is, well, it's kind of, it's a slightly recherche one, isn't it? But also an intriguing one. I wouldn't say recherche, Tom. I think it's fair to say since we started this podcast, The Rest is History, there have been some subjects that you've been very keen to do.
感谢收听《过往皆史》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《过往皆史》，我们的世界杯马拉松节目仍在继续，今天我们来到了远东，我们来到了韩国，也就是流行音乐和《鱿鱼游戏》的国度，呃，还有多米尼克，嗯，是的，汤姆。好吧，我把话晾在那儿，因为我本希望你能接话，因为你今天选择的主题，嗯，可以说是一个有点冷门的主题，对吧？但也是一个引人入胜的主题。我不觉得冷门，汤姆。我觉得可以这么说，自从我们创办这个播客《过往皆史》以来，有一些主题是你非常热衷于做的。
So you've often said you'd like to do, you know, the Roman emperors. One day you will give us your podcast about the historical Jesus. Well, for Christmas, it's going to be a Christmas treat. Voted for by the fans, which everyone's much looking forward to. And another subject that I know
所以你经常说你想做，你知道的，罗马皇帝。总有一天你会给我们带来关于历史上的耶稣的播客。好吧，作为圣诞礼物，这将是一个圣诞大礼。由粉丝投票选出，大家对此都非常期待。还有另一个主题，我知道
you've often shown an enormous amount of interest in, you've said you're particularly passionate, I believe, about early modern South Korean poetry. Is that right, Tom? Love it. Absolutely love it.
你经常表现出极大的兴趣，我相信你曾说过你特别热衷于早期现代南朝鲜诗歌。是这样吗，汤姆？太爱了。绝对是真爱。
Well, you know, I mean, right from the beginning, I would say we have to do an episode on that. Because that is what the punters will want. It's a subject that we've often had a lot of requests about. People have said, when are you going to do the... It's Hitler, Tudors, 16th century South Korean poetry. It's just endless. But today is the day.
好吧，你知道的，我的意思是，从一开始我就觉得我们必须做一期关于这个的主题。因为这才是大众想看的。这是一个我们经常收到很多请求的主题。人们会问，你们什么时候打算做……是希特勒、都铎王朝、16th世纪南朝鲜诗歌。简直没完没了。但今天就是这一天。
Sorry, it may seem a cliche to you, Tom, but we're going to be talking about the South Korean poet Hwang Jin-hee. They do that on all the other podcasts. Let's cut to the... Has Dan Snow done it? Yes, he does it every other week. So let's cut to the chase. How familiar are you with the institution of the Ksieng?
抱歉，对你来说这可能显得是个陈词滥调，汤姆，但我们今天要聊的是南朝鲜诗人黄真伊。他们在别的播客里都这么干。让我们直接切入……丹·斯诺做过吗？做过，他每隔一周就会做一次。所以我们直奔主题吧。你对妓生这个阶层有多熟悉？
The Korean geisha girls. It is. Very good. Very good, Tom. Yeah. Ksieng were, they were women from outcast families or kind of slave families. And basically they were trained to be courtesans and they provided entertainment and sort of comfort, I suppose you would say, if you were being euphemistic
朝鲜的艺妓。就是这样。非常好。非常棒，汤姆。是的。妓生是，她们来自被抛弃的家庭或是某种奴隶家庭。基本上，她们被训练成歌妓，提供娱乐和某种安慰，如果你用委婉的说法的话
to powerful men but is it is it so how i mean how like the geishas are they kind of modeled on them um no i wouldn't say common cultural matrix i'm probably not as familiar with japanese history to be completely frank with you as i could be um but i think they are not influenced they're not sort of modeled on them at all so i'll explain where they sort of come from so korea let's do a bit about the history of korea generally the idea of korea and the korean state comes from a kingdom called the kingdom of goryeo which was um sort of flourished from about the 10th century to the 14th century and i think it's fair to say at the outset two things. One, neither of us is really an expert on Korean history.
为权势男性提供服务。但这是——所以，这——就像艺妓一样，她们是按照艺妓的模式塑造的吗？呃，不，我不会说是共同的文化矩阵。坦白说，我对日本历史的熟悉程度可能还不够。呃，但我认为她们不受其影响，根本不是按那种模式塑造的。所以我来解释一下她们是怎么来的。所以朝鲜，让我们大致讲讲朝鲜的历史。朝鲜和朝鲜国的概念源于一个叫做高丽的王国，它大约在10世纪到14世纪左右繁荣发展。我想一开始有两点是可以肯定的。第一，我们俩其实都不是朝鲜历史专家。
Is that fair to say, Tom? I think that is fair. And secondly, although we both obviously do speak Korean. But not medieval, is it? Medieval Korean is not really our specialism. So it was in the period from the 10th century to the 14th century, sort of three regions basically become merged into a single entity, which is the basis of modern day Korea. And at this point, Korea was Buddhist.
这样说对吗，汤姆？我觉得这很公允。第二，虽然我们俩显然都会说朝鲜语。但不是中世纪的，对吧？中世纪朝鲜语并不是我们的专长。所以在10世纪到14世纪的这段时期里，大约三个地区基本上融合成了一个单一的实体，这就是现代朝鲜的基础。而在当时，朝鲜是信奉佛教的。
So this kingdom, the kingdom of Goryeo, is the sort of golden age of Buddhism in Korea. And there's all kinds of sort of trade and industry with other sort of Buddhist places and all this kind of stuff. And then that falls in the end of the 14th century and it's replaced by another sort of great sort of kingdom, which is called the Kingdom of Chosyon. The big difference is religious. It will please you to hear. The new one isn't Buddhist.
所以这个王国，高丽王国，是朝鲜佛教的黄金时代。这里有与其它佛教圣地的各种贸易和工业，诸如此类的事情。然后它在14世纪末灭亡了，取而代之的是另一个伟大的王国，叫做朝鲜王国。最大的不同是宗教信仰。你听了可能会高兴。新王国不信佛教。
It's Confucian. Confucianism gives way. So Confucianism replaces buddhism so in both cases influenced by you know this is reflecting what's happening in china yeah absolutely so china is the big the big influence so that's um great joseon kingdom which runs from 1392 to 1897 this is the sort of golden age of korean identity of Korea's sort of maturity. Most of the things in modern Korea, so culture, language, literature, all these things are traced back from this period. And one really important element of it is the institution of the gisaeng. So these are the sort of, as you said, the courtesans.
它是儒教。儒教取代了。所以儒教取代了佛教。因此，在这两种情况下，都受到了，你知道的，这反映了中国正在发生的事情。是的，绝对的。所以中国是最大的影响因素。这就是那个伟大的朝鲜王国，从1392年一直延续到1897年。这是朝鲜身份认同和朝鲜走向成熟的黄金时代。现代朝鲜的大多数事物，比如文化、语言、文学，都可以追溯到这一时期。而其中一个非常重要的元素就是妓生制度。所以这些就是，正如你所说，歌妓。
There were a few thousand of them, not a huge number. And they were spread throughout the country. So mostly in cities, but also in sort of smaller towns and villages. They're first mentioned in about the 11th century. And they're sort of entertainers. They work, they do needlework, they play music, all of these kinds of things, apart from their, you know, as well as their kind of sexual services. They are very, very highly educated.
她们有几千人，数量不算巨大。而且她们遍布全国各地。主要在城市，但也分布在一些小镇和村庄里。她们最早在11世纪左右被提及。她们算是艺人，她们从事女红、演奏音乐，除了她们的，你知道的，以及她们的某种性服务之外，还做这些事情。她们受过非常非常高的教育。
So they're a bit like Hetaera in ancient Greece, perhaps. Exactly. So that's a nice comparison. Yes. They're sort of an odd social status, because on the one hand, they are the lowest group in society. So they're what's called chonmin, which means they're kind of slaves, of like churls or something and that's that's a hereditary status so if you're at that level of that bottom stratum your children will inherit it as well it's a kind of car system it's cars exactly so they're considered unclean and other people who are in that chonmin stratum are butchers and entertainers and shamans and sorcerers exactly exactly um eventually the kixiang are owned by they're considered slaves owned by the government they are they're better treated than normal slaves because they're considered very highly educated very very
所以她们有点像古希腊的交际花（Hetaera），也许吧。完全正确。所以这是一个很好的比较。是的。她们的社会地位有点奇怪，因为一方面，她们是社会最低的阶层。所以她们被称为“贱民”（chonmin），这意味着她们有点像奴隶，类似于农夫之类的人。这是一个世袭的身份，如果你处于那个底层的阶层，你的孩子也会继承这一点。这是一种种姓制度，就是种姓，完全正确。所以她们被视为不洁的人，而在那个贱民阶层中的其他人还有屠夫、艺人、萨满和巫师，完全正确，完全正确。呃，最终妓生归属于，她们被视为政府拥有的奴隶。她们比普通奴隶受到更好的对待，因为她们被认为受过极高教育、受过极高
highly trained and so this is this is a kind of hereditary thing that you're you're a girl born to one of these women and then are you then are you then kind of hereditary thing that you're a girl born to one of these women. And are you then kind of raised to be very educated? Well, some are, absolutely, yes. Some definitely are the daughters of other Qixiang, but some of them are people from poor families who can't afford to maintain their girls. So get sold into slavery. Exactly.
专业训练。所以这是一个世袭的事情，你是一个生在这些女性之中的女孩，然后你——你是——然后你会被抚养得很有教养吗？嗯，有些是的，绝对的。有些确实是其他妓生的女儿，但也有一些是来自无力抚养女孩的贫困家庭的人。所以被卖为奴隶。完全正确。
Now today, I suppose we would say, wouldn't we, and some of the people listening to this podcast, they would say, these are sex slaves. This is a terrible business. And of course, throughout 21st century eyes, it is. But on the other hand, I think people in medieval Korea might well have thought of this quite differently. The weird thing is, although they're the lowest possible status, they also do have a kind of prestige because they are so highly educated and they are seen as artists and writers. So they produce music and they produce poetry. And presumably their services are bought by people who can set them up and provide them with comfort and security. Exactly. They're trained. are they're trained eventually they're trained by the government so this is kind of state-run female education so basically you
如今，我想我们会说，对吧，听这个播客的一些人会说，这些是性奴隶。这是一桩可怕的买卖。当然，透过21世纪的眼光来看，确实如此。但另一方面，我认为中世纪朝鲜的人们对这一点的看法可能会完全不同。奇怪的是，尽管她们的地位最低，但她们也有一种声望，因为她们受过极高的教育，被视为艺术家和作家。所以她们创作音乐，也创作诗歌。据推测，她们的服务是由那些能够资助她们并为她们提供舒适和安全保障的人购买的。完全正确。她们接受了培训。
enter the you enter the workforce as it were when you're about 16 or 17 and your career is over actually pretty quickly so your career can be over within five or ten years i don't know whether that's because you've become pregnant and had started to have children, but it might be because you become the concubine of a sort of powerful patron who buys you out of the service. Well, maybe it's like Hollywood, you know, because that's a stereotype, isn't it? You're showgirl, district attorney, driving Miss Daisy, isn't it? It's the three ages of Hollywood actors. Is that right? Showgirls, what was the third one?
她们接受了培训，最终由政府进行培训。所以这是一种国家运营的女性教育。基本上，你大约在16、17岁时进入劳动力市场，而你的职业生涯其实结束得相当快。所以你的职业生涯可能在五到十年内就结束了。我不知道这是不是因为你怀孕了并开始生孩子，但也可能是因为你成为了某个强大的赞助人的妾，他把你从服务中赎了身。好吧，也许这就像好莱坞，你知道的，因为那是一种刻板印象，不是吗？你是歌舞女郎、地方检察官、《为黛西小姐开车》，对吧？这是好莱坞演员的三个年龄段。是这样吗？歌舞女郎，第三个是什么？
Driving Miss Daisy. And the middle one? District Attorney. District Attorney? For women in Hollywood. So if you're a female actor in Hollywood, you have your time in the sun, sex symbol, and then suddenly the calls dry up.
《为黛西小姐开车》。那中间那个呢？地方检察官。地方检察官？好莱坞的女演员。所以如果你是好莱坞的女演员，你有你的高光时刻，性感尤物，然后电话突然就不响了。
Yeah. Geena Davis has an autobiography out at the moment, which apparently is brilliantly funny and very good on all this. So maybe it's that. Maybe you just have, you know, you have, as one of these entertainers, you have your time in the sun and then it's all over. And presumably if that is the case, then you need to bank your youth and looks. You do.
吉娜·戴维斯目前出了一本自传，据说非常搞笑，而且对这些事情的剖析很到位。所以也许就是这样。也许你只是，你知道的，作为这些艺人之一，你拥有你的高光时刻，然后这一切就结束了。如果真是这样的话，那你大概就需要把你的青春和美貌变现。确实需要。
It's very important you do that or else you end up on the scrap heap or what happens? Most of the former Qixiang actually go to work in taverns they become basically landladers okay so so that's the sort of trajectory it's a bit like sportsmen owning pubs back in the 70s for leeds united footballers from 1973 exactly so basically you have this kisang house where you all kind of it's it's much too simplistic to call it a brothel I suppose it's a sort of because it's a much it's a house of entertainment and the arts and they're inspected twice a month officials sort of inspect them I don't know how intimate these inspections are they have to do kind of continued professional training in sort of dance and music and stuff a lot of them will have a patron who's called a gibu and he might be an official or a soldier or or a sort of um you know sort of
这非常重要，否则你就会落得一无所有，或者会发生什么？大多数前妓生实际上都去酒馆工作，她们基本上成了女掌柜。好吧，所以这就是这种轨迹。这有点像70年代利兹联足球运动员退役后开酒吧，1973年的利兹联球员一样。完全正确。所以基本上你拥有这个妓生馆，你们都在某种程度上——把这叫做妓院实在是太简单化了，我想它算是一个娱乐和艺术之所。她们每个月接受两次检查，官员们会对她们进行检查。我不知道这些检查有多私密。她们必须在舞蹈、音乐等方面接受持续的职业培训。她们中的许多人会有一个赞助人，被称为“基夫”（gibu），他可能是一名官员、一名士兵，或者某种，呃，你知道的，
a local bigwig or something like that so you would try to have one of these things and hopefully in the long run you could just become his his concubine um but sometimes there's a bit of conflict do any of them ever marry that never happens no i don't think really because i think you're so low status right and i think once you enter this world that's not really a career open to you but this world is i mean it's better than being poor and being a beggar or you know something like that this is this is a quite it's very hard to sort of pin down. But I think because our mentality is just not attuned to this world. Yeah, the nature of the status.
当地的大人物之类的。所以你会努力争取这样一个人，希望长远来看，你能成为他的小妾。呃，但有时也会有一些冲突。她们中有人会结婚吗？这从不发生，不。我觉得真的不会，因为我觉得你的社会地位太低了，对吧？而且我认为一旦你进入了这个世界，那并不是一个向你开放的职业道路。但这个世界，我的意思是，它比贫穷和当乞丐或诸如此类的事情要好。这是一种，这很难明确界定。但我认为因为我们的心态根本不适应这个世界。是的，这种地位的本质。
Because it's simultaneously very low status, but also quite prestigious in a weird way, if that makes sense. I suppose, as you said, like a Greek hetara. Yeah. I mean, that's the same, right? Pretty much, yeah. So one thing that the Qixiang were very, very known for is poetry. They are trained to write poetry, and they write these verses called sijo,
因为它的地位既非常低下，但以一种奇怪的方式又相当有声望，如果这讲得通的话。我想，正如你所说，就像古希腊的交际花。是的。我的意思是，这也是一样的，对吧？差不多，是的。妓生非常非常出名的一点就是诗歌。她们接受过写诗的培训，她们写这种被称为“时调”（sijo）的诗句，
which are kind of the equivalent of haikus. So they're very short, kind of three lines or something. And they're often very melancholy they're about kind of bereavement i imagine your life must be pretty melancholy yeah i'm sure it's not a bundle of laughs but you might put some of the some famous kisang um poems were written they're almost like love poems to great scholars and And their poems are a big part of Korean literature, so people will study them in school. And unlike a lot of other women in Korean society,
这有点类似于俳句。所以它们非常短，大概三行左右。而且它们通常非常忧郁，是关于生离死别之类的。我猜你的生活一定很忧郁。是的，我确信这不是一件让人开怀大笑的事。但你可能会写一些著名的妓生诗篇。它们几乎像是写给伟大学者和名士的情诗。而且她们的诗歌是朝鲜文学的重要组成部分，所以人们会在学校里学习它们。与朝鲜社会中许多其他女性不同，
sort of late medieval, early modern period, Kishin move around. So they're moving between different social groups and between different kind of parts of the social landscape. And that means they are, they're figures in stories and they're kind of mobile so it kind of gives them a centrality exactly in in medieval culture it does indeed it does indeed because by and large most medieval poets in europe are men exactly and that's what makes them so remarkable. And the most remarkable one of all is a woman called Huang Jinni. So her Gixiang name was Myongwol, which means bright moon, but she is by far the most famous Gixiang of the Chosyong dynasty.
比如中世纪晚期和近代早期的女性，妓生是四处流动的。所以她们在不同的社会群体之间以及社会景观的不同部分之间穿梭。这意味着她们是故事中的人物，而且她们具有流动性，这赋予了她们一种中心地位。完全正确。在中世纪文化中，确实如此。确实如此，因为总的来说，欧洲的大多数中世纪诗人都是男性。完全正确，这正是她们如此非凡的原因。而其中最非凡的一位是一位名叫黄真伊的女性。所以她的妓生名字叫“明月”，意思是明亮的月亮，但她绝对是朝鲜王朝最著名的妓生。
Should we take a break at this point? Yes, because we are going to focus, we're going to focus on this great character. Wonderful. Okay. Really look forward to that. We'll see you in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我们是不是该在这个时候休息一下？是的，因为我们要把焦点，我们要把焦点放在这位伟大的传奇人物身上。太棒了。好的。非常期待。我们几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《过往皆 entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、加更节目并优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back. We are in Korea, the land of female medieval poets. Dominic, which you were brilliantly explicating in the first half. I think brilliantly is pretty strong, Tom. It was brilliant. And you have introduced the most famous one of the lot. Hwang Jin-hee, Tom. She lived from about 1500 to about 1560.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回来。我们身处朝鲜，这个盛产中世纪女诗人的国度。多米尼克，你在前半场对此进行了精彩的阐述。“精彩”这个词未免太夸张了吧，汤姆。这确实很精彩。而且你已经介绍了其中最著名的一位。黄真伊，汤姆。她大约生活在1500年至1560年间。
She is a massive figure in Korean culture, as I'll go on to explain. So what's her kind of, well, she's not Shakespeare, but what? Maybe she's Byron, Tom. Okay. That would appeal to you. Yeah, it would. I mean.
她在朝鲜文化中是一个巨擘，正如我接下来要解释的那样。那么她大概是怎样的人——好吧，她不是莎士比亚，那是谁？也许她是拜伦，汤姆。好吧。这倒挺合你的胃口。是的，会的。我的意思是。
I love her already. I only said that to pander to you, to be honest with you. I love her. So what do we know about her? We think she's the daughter of a scribe called John Hun Gyum. Oh, so like Diocletian. But John Hun Gyum is a woman. Yeah.
我已经爱上她了。说实话，我那样说只是为了迎合你。我爱她。那么我们对她了解多少？我们认为她是一个名叫全弘谦（John Hun Gyum）的书记官的女儿。哦，就像戴克里先一样。但全弘谦是个女人。是的。
And the story goes that her mother was washing underneath a bridge when a handsome man, a politician's son called Huang Qingsha, came across her and they fell in love instantly, as people often seem to have done in the medieval early modern period so i mean that's extraordinary especially by bridges by bridges so presumably a kind of liminal space oh very good very good very good podcasting's game was academia's loss i think it's fair to say um you could be decolonizing a curriculum right now and instead you're wasting you're throwing
故事是这样的：她的母亲在一个桥底下洗衣服时，一个英俊的男子——一个政客的儿子，名叫黄庆暇（Huang Qingsha）——遇到了她，两人一见钟情，就像在中世纪和近代早期人们似乎经常做的那样。所以我的意思是，这太不可思议了，尤其是在桥下。在桥下，所以大概是一个边缘空间。哦，非常棒，非常棒，非常棒。播客界的收获就是学术界的损失，我觉得可以这么说。呃，你现在本可以去致力于课程去殖民化，而你却把时间浪费在、把
your life away listening to you titter exactly so he came back that night they they drank together they spent the night together and huang genie was the result and obviously because she's born out of wedlock does the father just gallop off he yeah he just has nothing more to do with her that's the end of him we don't he will not reappear in this story, Tom. She's very, very beautiful. Her mother brings her up. Her mother herself loved music and dance, so educates her in all this sort of stuff.
生命浪费在听别人傻笑上。完全正确。所以他那天晚上回来了，他们一起喝酒，共度良宵，黄真伊就此诞生。而且显然因为她是私生女，父亲就这样扬长而去吗？是的，他跟她再无瓜葛，这就是他的结局。他不会在这个故事里再次出现了，汤姆。她非常非常漂亮。她的母亲抚养她长大。她的母亲本人热爱音乐和舞蹈，所以在这方面培养了她。
Why did she become a Gi Xiang? Well, here's why. Because there's a story that one day, a funeral procession was going past her house, and she looked out, and the coffin stopped outside her house because she was reading her poetry and the coffin wouldn't budge it was listening to her reading her poems that's fabulous what a wonderful wonderful image and it only moved when she ran out and she pulled off her skirt her outer skirt and, and threw it over the coffin. And only at that point did the coffin move again, which is a very strange occurrence. Later on, Tom, it turned out that the coffin was the body of an aristocratic man who had
她为什么会成为一名妓生？好吧，原因如下：有个故事说，有一天，一个送葬队伍从她家门外经过，她向外望去，棺材在她家门前停了下来，因为她在诵读自己的诗歌，棺材竟然一动不动。它在听她读诗。太棒了。多么美妙绝伦的画面。直到她跑出去，脱下她的裙子——她的外裙，
fallen in love with her, but couldn't marry her because of her low status. And he had died of a broken heart. She's 15 years old and the story goes that at that point she um she realized her tremendous appeal and she decided forthwith to become a a kiss yang so that's the story right the more prosaic explanation yeah is that is that her mother couldn't afford to keep her and sent her away. She therefore became a courtesan. So you can choose, you know. Are you a romantic?
并把它盖在棺材上，棺材才重新移动。只有在那时，棺材才再次移动，这是一个非常奇怪的现象。后来，汤姆，事实证明，棺材里躺着一个贵族男子的遗体，他曾深深地爱上她，却因为她低微的身份而无法娶她。他是因为心碎而死的。她当时15岁，故事说，就在那个时候，她呃，她意识到了自己巨大的吸引力，并当机立断决定成为一名妓生。这就是故事，对吧？更世俗的解释是，嗯，是她母亲无力抚养她，就把她送走了。因此她成为了一名歌妓。所以你可以选择，你知道的。你是个浪漫主义者吗？
I'm going for the former. Yeah, obviously. We're romantics on the rest of history, so we believe the former story. She starts out as a courtesan. She's very sort of successful. There's a story told about her when she's quite young. One of her first trips, she gets basically her own gibu, her own patron or
我选前一个。是的，显然如此。我们在《过往皆史》里都是浪漫主义者，所以我们相信前一个故事。她以歌妓身份出道。她非常成功。有一个关于她年轻时的故事。在她的第一次远行中，她基本上找到了自己的“基夫”，也就是她自己的赞助人，或者说
sort of a strange sort of patron and this one is this one is alive presumably yes yes he's alive so that's good he's a man called yi xian and they go off to the diamond mountains oh wonderful but they run out of money and so they they beg oh and yes so he's a he's a dud as a patron then. Well, he's a terrible dud, Tom, because at one point they're in such dire straits that she has to sell her favors to a monk. So what does this story tell us? I mean, I read academic explanations of what this story told us. I mean, I think this story tells you nothing good but but apparently this story tells us that um she can deal with men as an equal that she uh can use her sexuality to get what she wants and that she's very frank and kind of authentic and she doesn't care what she does i mean that's one way of
某种奇怪的赞助人。这个还活着，大概吧？是的，是的，他还活着。那挺好的。他是一个名叫李贤（Yi Xian）的人，他们一起去了金刚山。哦，太棒了。但他们花光了钱，所以他们只好乞讨。哦，是的，所以作为一个赞助人，他简直是个废柴。好吧，他是个彻头彻尾的废柴，汤姆，因为有一次他们的处境如此绝望，以至于她不得不将自己的身体出卖给一个和尚。那么这个故事告诉了我们什么？我的意思是，我读过对这个故事的学术解释。我的意思是，我觉得这个故事没讲什么好东西，但显然这个故事告诉我们，呃，她可以把男人当作平等的人对待，她，呃，可以利用自己的性吸引力得到她想要的东西，而且她非常坦诚、真实，她不在乎自己做什么。我的意思是，这算是一种解读吧。而且据说她这种坦诚是她吸引力很大的一部分。所以据说她不戴任何大多数妓生都会戴的首饰。她不化任何妆，也不穿华丽的衣服，因为她天生丽质。是的，但也是因为她在开创一种新风格，那就是不加修饰、真实自然，是的，所有这些。她的诗歌也是这样的吗？
interpreting it i suppose and it's sort of said this sort of thing about her frankness is a big part of her appeal so it said that she doesn't wear any jewelry which most kisang did she doesn't wear any makeup or fancy clothes because she's so naturally beautiful yeah but also because she's pioneering a new kind of style which is unadorned authentic yeah all this sort of thing and it's her poetry like that well i'm glad you mentioned the poetry because i'm about to get onto the poetry. Because she's famous because of this interaction with the monk. Let's not delve too deeply into that.
好吧，我很高兴你提到诗歌，因为我正要切入诗歌。因为她因为与这个和尚的交往而闻名。我们不要过分深入探讨那个。
But she's also famous because of her verses, which have survived. So I said beforehand that there's a kind of formula called a sijo, which is older than a haiku. It's quite similar. They normally have three lines obviously when they're translated that doesn't quite follow the same format i'll probably read it in english rather than korean so this is a very probably her most famous poem tom i will divide this long november light and coil by coil lay it under a warm spring blanket. And roll by roll, when my frozen love returns, I will unfold it to the night. That's wonderful.
但她也因为流传下来的诗句而闻名。所以我之前说过，有一种被称为“时调”的格式，它比俳句更古老。它非常相似。它们通常有三行。显然，当它们被翻译时，并不能完全遵循相同的格式。我可能会用英语而不是朝鲜语来读它。所以这是一首，大概是她最著名的诗了，汤姆：“我将这漫长的十一月之夜裁下一段，把它一圈又一圈地叠放在温暖的春日被褥下。等到我冰冻的爱意归来，我将把它一卷又一卷，在夜里缓缓展开。”太棒了。
You like that? Yeah. That's translated by David Bannon in the Hangul Herald. I love it. Apparently, the double meaning that you don't get in English is that the word that she uses for her beloved, her frozen love, which is David Bannon's translation, it means somebody,
你喜欢这个？是的。这是大卫·班农（David Bannon）在《韩文先驱报》上的译文。我很喜欢。据说，英语中没有体现出的双关语是，她用来形容她所爱之人的词——她冰冻的爱意，这是大卫·班农的翻译——意味着某人，
there's some kind of wordplay. It means both your sweetheart and somebody who has been frozen by winter. Another famous poem is called Full Moon. And this is some sort of play on her Gis-Yang name, which also means bright mood. Yeah. There was a very famous
这里面有一些双关语。它既指你的甜心，也指被冬天冻僵的人。另一首著名的诗叫做《满月》。这可以说是对她妓生名字的一种双关，她的名字也意味着明月。是的。有一个非常著名的
sort of scholar called byok kiesu who was famous for his virtue and his sort of uh yeah asceticist chastity yeah so you can imagine what uh young genie set out to seduce him and indeed did seduce him this is the this is the poem that she wrote to him do not boast of your speed oh blue green stream running by the hills. Once you've reached the wide ocean, you can return no more. Why not stay here and rest when moonlight stuffs the empty hills?
学者叫朴季洙（Byok Kiesu），他以美德和这种呃，苦行僧般的贞洁而闻名。所以你可以想象，黄真伊是如何着手勾引他的，并且确实勾引了他。这就是她写给他的诗：“莫夸溪水流经山间时速度迅捷，一旦汇入辽阔的大海，便再也无法返回。当明月充盈了空寂的山峦，为何不留在此处小憩？”
Stuffed. No, that's what I thought, Tom, that stuffs was an unusual choice. Can a hill be stuffed with moonlight? I mean, maybe it can. It's got a cave. Yeah, I suppose so. That's an image we shouldn't really pursue.
“充盈（Stuffed）”。不，我当时就是这么想的，汤姆，觉得用“充盈”这个词是个不寻常的选择。山峦怎么能被月光“充盈”呢？我的意思是，也许可以吧。它有个山洞。是的，我想是的。这是一个我们不该深究的画面。
So the thing that she's most famous for, Tom, is her riddle. And I should have flagged this up at the beginning because I think people would have looked forward to me asking you this riddle. It's like Bilbo and Gollum. Basically, the thing was you could come to see her and only if you passed the test of the riddle would you be able to spend the night with her or whatever. Now, the riddle was known as the Geomiligo Idubolchul.
所以她最出名的事情，汤姆，是她的谜语。我本该在一开始就提出来，因为我猜大家会很期待我向你出这个谜语。这就像比尔博和古卢姆。基本上，规则是你可以去见她，只有通过了谜语的测试，你才能和她共度良宵之类的。这个谜语被称为“琴尾里句二不出处”（Geomiligo Idubolchul）。
And I don't know what to say to you, Tom, but that is the riddle. That's the riddle? Yeah. I just have a policy of not answering riddles. I just don't really approve of them. And Dominic, I mean, not to be offensive. Yeah. You are not as personable as Huang Jini.
我不知道该对你说什么，汤姆，但这确实是那个谜语。这就是谜语？是的。我只是有一个原则，不回答谜语。我实在不太赞成它们。而且多米尼克，我的意思是不是冒犯。是的。你没有黄真伊那么有魅力。
No. And so I don't want to spend the night with you. Okay, fair enough. So I'm not going to answer it. Okay. Well, I'll tell you the answer because I don't think you do know the answer. The answer is in the title, Jiumiligu Idibuljul. I'm reading this from what I've read.
没有。所以我不想和你过夜。好吧，那好吧。所以我不会回答的。好吧，那我告诉你答案，因为我觉得你确实不知道答案。答案就在标题里：“琴尾里句二不出处”。我是根据我读到的内容来读的。
Yes, understood. Understood. If you combine the variations in the title of the characters, if you fiddle with it in some way, the first part, Jumiligu, creates the Chinese character that means spoken word. And the second part is day.
是的，明白了。明白了。如果你把标题中字符的变化组合起来，如果你以某种方式摆弄它，前半部分“琴尾里句”创造了意为“说出的词”的中文字符。后半部分是“日”。
Right. And then those words together, you get the Chinese word that means consent. Right. And then you're in. Wow. So I think you had to be there really. Probably.
对。然后把这些词放在一起，你就得到了意为“同意”的中文字符。对。然后你就进去了。哇。所以我觉得你当时必须在场才行。大概吧。
Anyway. Right. And then you win. Wow. So I think you had to be there, really. Probably. Anyway, only one person won. So you're actually in good company. Yeah, you're in good company. So she was a courtesan, but she only ever slept with one person? Well, this was the monk. So the monk got it. But presumably the guy... The monk is pre-riddle okay and and and the useless
无论如何。对。然后你就赢了。哇。所以我觉得你当时必须在场才行。大概吧。无论如何，只有一个人赢了。所以你其实并不孤单。是的，你并不孤单。所以她是个歌妓，但她一生只和一个男人睡过？好吧，这就是那个和尚。所以和尚得到了。但据推测那个家伙——和尚是在谜语之前，好吧，还有那个没用的
patron yeah and what happens to him just just got the boot at some point did he so does she did she end up with a with a rich and powerful patron who set her up for life or what happened to her she hung around with a scholar he's the guy who actually solved the riddle um it was a guy called uh shou kyung dok she said that he was one of the three wonders of the k-song area that's what she said the other wonders were herself i love i she sounds great and the pakion falls okay but oh i forgot to say about the monk he had been celibate for 30 years yeah and then and then she yeah stole his heart so tremendous figure but what happened to him after he'd the monk or the scholar the monk no i mean you're asking for details that i just don't know okay that nobody knows that's the nature the nature of history yeah okay there's an awful lot of uncertainty
赞助人，是的。那他怎么了？在某个时候被甩了，是吗？所以她最后有没有和一个既富有又权势的赞助人在一起，是那个赞助人安顿了她的余生，还是她发生了什么事？她和一个学者混在一起，就是那个真正解开谜语的家伙。那是一个名叫徐经德（Shou Kyung Dok）的人。她说他是开城地区的三个奇迹之一。她就是这么说的。另外两个奇迹是她自己。我爱——她听起来太棒了。而朴渊瀑布，好吧。哦，我忘了说那个和尚了，他已经守身如玉30年了，是的，然后，然后她，是的，偷走了他的心。真是一个了不起的人物，但他在那之后怎么样了？那个和尚还是那个学者？那个和尚。不，我的意思是你在问我一些我根本不知道的细节。好吧，没人知道。这就是历史的本质，本质。是的，好吧。这里有非常多的不确定性。
but i imagine that she's such a famous person that actually these people, people would have constructed narratives about them. We shall come to the constructed narratives. She died perhaps when she was 60, perhaps not. You know, it's very unclear. And she was buried in a simple grave on a riverbank in Kaesong. She'd written these nice poems and there were all these folk tales about her seducing monks. And so everybody was delighted with that.
但我猜她是一个如此著名的人物，以至于人们其实会围绕他们构建各种叙事。我们稍后会谈到这些构建出来的叙事。她去世时可能60岁，也可能不是。你知道的，这很不确定。她被安葬在开城河岸的一个简单坟墓里。她写过这些美好的诗篇，并且流传着关于她勾引和尚的各种民间传说。所以每个人都对此津津乐道。
So there are two TV series and two different films all about her produced in recent years. They all have the same title. They're all called Hwang Jin-hee. However, she's not thought of highly. So she was from what's now North Korea, and all this carry on, interfering with monks, riddles, writing poems. All this happened in what's now North Korea. And all this carry on, interfering with monks, riddles, writing poems, all this happened in what's now North Korea.
因此近年来制作了两部电视剧和两部不同的电影，全都是关于她的。它们都有相同的名字，都叫《黄真伊》。然而，人们对她的评价并不高。因为她来自现在的朝鲜，而所有这些胡闹——干扰和尚、猜谜语、写诗，这一切都发生在现在的朝鲜。而所有这些胡闹——干扰和尚、猜谜语、写诗，这一切都发生在现在的朝鲜。
The North Koreans are not keen on this at all. Why? They don't celebrate it. Because they're very puritanical. They don't approve of prostitution. They also don't approve of the descendants of Kishang. So the biggest Kishang school of all was located in pyongyang the capital of north korea right and it's full of people who are descendants of kishang um but the north korean communist regime regard
朝鲜人对此一点也不热衷。为什么？他们不庆祝这个。因为他们非常清教徒式。他们不赞成卖淫。他们也不赞成妓生的后代。所以最大的妓生学校就位于朝鲜首都平壤，对吧？那里到处都是妓生的后代。但是朝鲜的共产主义政权认为
them as having tainted blood because of their their role but they were workers well i don't think it sees it that again this goes back to their ambiguous social status um so they are not celebrated and they are sort of told to feel that they're full of shame and stuff. Even though she is arguably the most famous North Korean, not that it was North Korea, apart from various bad guys, she's not celebrated there as much as she should be. But she's celebrated in South Korea.
他们的血液因为他们的角色而被玷污了。但他们是劳动者。嗯，我不认为它是那样看的。这又回到了他们含糊不清的社会地位。所以他们没有受到庆祝，并且被灌输一种充满羞耻感之类的感觉。尽管她可以说是除了各种坏蛋之外最著名的朝鲜人——虽然当时还不是朝鲜——但她在那里并没有得到应有的庆祝。不过她在韩国受到了庆祝。
She is hugely. Well, I told you, two TV series, two films, which you should report back in a future edition of The Rest is History. Well, I love The Squid Game. Right. So who knows? Who knows, indeed. And I love a glamorous medieval poet.
她受到了极大的庆祝。嗯，我告诉过你了，两部电视剧，两部电影，你应该在《过往皆史》未来的节目中对此进行报道。好吧，我很喜欢《鱿鱼游戏》。对。所以谁知道呢？确实，谁知道呢。而且我很喜欢迷人的中世纪女诗人。
Well, there's not perhaps as much about her. She's one of those people in history who, when you sort of dig into it, there's probably not as much reliable evidence. That's fine. Well, Dominic, you know, it's not going to bother me. No. Well, you were very sceptical. She's a kind of poetic Emma Hamilton.
好吧，关于她的资料可能没有那么多。她就是历史上的那种人物，当你去深入挖掘时，可能并没有那么多可靠的证据。没关系。好吧，多米尼克，你知道的，这不会困扰我的。不。好吧，你当时非常怀疑。她有点像诗歌界的艾玛·汉密尔顿。
Yes. Okay. Fair enough. That kind of thing. So that's Huang Jini. I mean, that's an excursion, a historical excursion, that frankly I never expected to make. But I'm glad that I did.
是的。好吧。有道理。诸如此类。这就是黄真伊。我的意思是，这是一次历史之旅，坦白说我从未想过自己会去。但我很高兴我去了。
Well, Dominic, what i'd say is that um this has been the great joy of doing these world cup episodes it's the way that things you assume kind of fairly immutable social forms gender relations all that kind of stuff how looked at through the prism of a different culture and a different age they can look so it shows you the infinitude ofitude of what human culture can be. I will end with a lovely poetry reading, because I know people enjoy these. This is another Huang Jinyi special called Thoughts of Manwoldai,
好吧，多米尼克，我想说的是，呃，这正是做这些世界杯节目的巨大乐趣所在，那就是当你透过一种不同的文化和不同的时代的棱镜去看待那些你认为相当一成不变的社会形式、性别关系、所有这些事情时，它们看起来是如此这般。它向你展示了人类文化的无限可能性。我将以一首美妙的诗歌朗诵来结束，因为我知道人们喜欢这些。这是另一首黄真伊的特别诗作，名为《满月台怀古》，
translated by A.N.A. Jung. An old temple sits forlornly by a brook from the palace. The evening sun bids a sad farewell to the trees. This tranquil season dissipates into only monks' dreams, leaving time layered in ice atop a broken pagoda. The phoenix has departed, the everyday sparrow in its stead. Cattle and sheep pull at the grass of ruins overflowing with azaleas. As I remember Songak Mountains flourishing in a flowering youth, Cattle and sheep pull at the grass of ruins overflowing with azaleas.
由A·N·A·荣（A.N.A. Jung）翻译。“古寺凄清伫立在宫苑的小溪旁，晚霞向树木依依惜别。这份宁静的季节消散在僧侣的梦境中，只留下层层冰霜覆盖在残破的宝塔顶端。凤凰已然离去，取而代之的是寻常的麻雀。牛羊在杂草丛生的废墟间啃食野草，这里曾经繁花似锦。当我回想起曾在盛放的青春中繁荣的松岳山，牛羊在杂草丛生的废墟间啃食野草，这里曾经繁花似锦。我意识到春天竟能如此酷似秋天。再见。”再见。感谢收听《过往皆史》。要想收听独家加更、抢先体验、无广告音频并访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《过往皆 Entertainment》。restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
As I remember Songak Mountains flourishing in a flowering youth, I realise how much spring could instead resemble autumn. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest is history pod.com i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《过往皆 Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、加更节目并优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。